de leur ferme familiale il ne reste que
quelques murs et cet amas de pierres
difficile pour Olga et son fils de
reconnaître leur maison après plusieurs
mois d'occupation russe à l'approche de
l'hiver il tente de sauver ce qui peut
encore l'être
les soldats une grenade et fait exploser
notre réserve
ce grain c'est le grain de toute la
communauté
mon mari doit acheter de nouvelles
machines agricoles
[Musique]
ils ont tout détruit
sur le bord des routes des mines et des
tanks fracassées témoins de la férocité
des combats tous les toits sont éventrés
le village anti a été détruit par les
bombardements successifs pour rentrer
chez elle loup de Mila doit désormais
passer par les fenêtres
et bien cette maison
je ne sais pas comment nous pouvons y
vivre tous les jours je me pose les
mêmes questions que faire par où dois-je
commencer si dans la région de harkif
les Ukrainiens tentent de survivre à
l'hiver au milieu des ruines 400 km plus
au sudar Herson c'est l'exode forcée
pour des centaines d'habitants dans la
précipitation ils ont emporté tout ce
qu'il pouvait la ville récemment libérée
fait face aux frappes massives de
l'artillerie russe
avant-hier un missile a touché notre
maison quatre appartements ont brûlés
les fenêtres ont éclatées nous ne
pouvons pas rester ici il n'y a ni
électricité ni au ni chauffage
ce qui n'ont pas de voiture Samas à la
gare ce soir-là sur le quai un train
direction l'ouest du pays où les
habitants résignés